heute sprechen wir über länder mit und
ohne artikel sowie in der englischen
sprache auch haben manche länder einen
artikel in der deutschen sprache und
manche anderen ländern nicht
hier ein beispiel ich kam aus
deutschland
deutschland hat keinen artikel aber ich
komme aus den usa
die usa haben einen artikel als erstes
stellen wir euch die länder vor die
einen artikel haben
hier sind alle länder mit einem
männlichen artikel der irak der iran der
jemen
der kongo der libanon der niger der oman
der senegal
der sudan der tschad und der vatikan
jetzt kommen alle länder mit einem
weiblichen artikel die dominikanische
republik die elfenbeinküste die
demokratische republik kongo die
republik kongo
aber manchmal sagt man auch der kongo
etwas verwirrend die mongolei die
schweiz die slowakei die ukraine die
türkei und die zentralafrikanische
republik und als wäre das nicht genug
gibt es auch noch länder die einen
artikel nur im plural haben das sind
diese hier die bahamas die färöer inseln
die kapverdischen inseln die komoren die
relativen die niederlande die
philippinen die salomonen die seychellen
und die usa also die vereinigten staaten
von amerika die usa und die vereinigten
arabischen emirate und jetzt zeigen wir
euch einige beispiele mit einer
deklination wenn man die position
ausgenutzt benutzt man im deutschen den
da tief hier ein paar beispiele
ich komme aus dem irak
ich komme aus dem senegal weiblich ich
komme aus der schweiz
ich komme aus der ukraine im plural
ich komme aus den usa ohne artikeln
ich komme aus deutschland viel einfacher
wenn man die präposition in benutzt
benutzt man den akkusativ sobald man von
einer bewegung spricht also wenn ich von
einem ort zu einem anderen gehe
benutze ich aktiv ich fahre in den iran
ich fliege in die türkei ich fahre in
die niederlande
aber ohne artikel kann man ihn hier
nicht benutzen dann sagt man nach
ich fahre nach polen ich fahre nach
england wenn man die präposition in
benutzt um einen ort zu beschreiben an
dem man gerade ist
dann benutzt man den dativ ich bin im
libanon
ich bin im kongo ich bin in der slowakei
weiblich ändert die den dativ zu der die
slowakei in der slowakei
ich bin in der elfenbeinküste und im
plural
ich bin in den usa ich bin in den
vereinigten arabischen emiraten jetzt
noch etwas besonderes zum schluss bei
inseln und inselgruppen benutzt man
meist auf ich bin auf den malediven wenn
die inseln und inselgruppen besonders
groß sind und man nicht weiß ob man
jetzt primär auf einer insel ist oder
schon auf einem großen land oder in
einem großen land kann man beides
benutzen man kann sagen ich bin in den
philippinen und ich bin auf den
philippinen
das war's für diese woche jetzt könnt
ihr das ganze noch üben bei uns ihr
könnt die präpositionen üben und die
artikel üben das ganze könnt ihr bei
bachelor machen werdet ein päckchen und
dann bekommt ihr einen link zu unserem
neuesten übungsplatz danke fürs
zuschauen und hier solltet ihr unbedingt
nach risikoarmen abonnieren
man freut sich ja mich wahnsinnig er
freut sich über jeden einzelnen
abonnenten tschüss und bis zur nächsten
woche
siehst du mich noch harmlos